now everyone loves leftovers and there's
no reason why you can't turn it into a
delicious dish to impress your family
across the holidays so I'm putting the
challenge to Mir to see if she can make
a perfect leftover dish in ten minutes
this is Ramsey and ten hi guys welcome
to Ramsey and ten I'm Mia Castro and
today I'm being challenged to use our
Thanksgiving leftovers today I'm using
ham instead of Turkey to make a
beautiful hash with some crispy potatoes
and a sunny-side-up egg on top this is
probably gonna take me less time than it
takes to find a parking spot on Black
Friday so I have some potatoes here and
I have some hot oil and we're just gonna
test it real quick if you don't have a
fryer what you do is you just drop the
potato and the second it sizzles that
means it's ready so we're just gonna
cook these first and you probably have
these on hand already left over from
your meal if they're cooked that's even
better it'll be faster and then we're
gonna move on to our onion so the
smaller you cut the onion the quicker it
cooks we're gonna go in a little butter
this is something that's really easy to
make for one person or a big crowd and
you can get it all done in under ten
minutes
so even if you're like Gordon and you
don't celebrate Thanksgiving cuz they
don't in the UK this is still a really
delicious and hearty breakfast for any
day your family is anything like mine
they're probably hungover from the day
before because they like their rum on
Thanksgiving so this will soak up all
that booze from the day before alright
should be good right there I'm just
gonna throw this right in with the
onions check our potatoes stir them
around you just want to cook them until
they're just golden brown because
they'll finish cooking in the pan then
while this is all cooking we're gonna
crack our eggs and get them cooking as
well
we want to make sure your pans not too
hot when you make your Sunny eggs and if
you miss anything the recipes in the
description below a good thing about
eggs especially sunny-side up is you
just put them on the pan and they cook
by themselves season minor a little bit
of pepper and you can use anything for
this hash if you have turkey use turkey
if you have pork that's fine
beef any meat really will work so we're
almost there everything's cooking I'm
gonna leave it alone and then just for a
nice finish I'm gonna slice some chives
and it'll give it a little bit of
freshness and some contrasting color so
you get a little fancy with this right
Gordon you're not the only fancy one so
you could be visiting family at home too
and this dish will blow them away and
it'll taste like you're making something
completely different than what you had
that day before my potatoes are almost
done and if you're not sure if they're
done test one perfect so we're just
gonna go straight into the pan and while
those potatoes are still hot you want to
season them that's when the salt sticks
a little more pepper and that eggs
looking beautiful it's ready to go so
I'm just gonna turn off the heat on it
do a little bit of chives in the hash I
like to add a little bit more butter to
finish just to make it richer it's
richer because butter is delicious and
it makes it taste better I'm gonna start
plating and like I said this dish can be
done in just under 10 minutes that egg
right on top
season your egg a little bit of salt
some pepper
and some chives
Gordon you may not know what
Thanksgiving is but you will after this
dish especially because I made it in
under ten minutes thanks for watching
Ramsay and ten and leave a comment below
on what your favorite Thanksgiving
leftovers are